for days we've talked about the
government's caution but this new 50
page plan is actually quite ambitious
now it begins incrementally from
Wednesday you should go to work if you
can't work from home but avoid public
transport if possible if you're in food
production construction distribution
manufacturing and scientific research
but not hospitality and non-essential
shops which stay shut people in England
now like those in Scotland are being
advised to wear face coverings in
enclosed spaces where social distancing
is hard like public transport they can
be homemade just don't buy surgical
masks because they're needed by
healthcare workers you can now spend as
much time as you like in parks and on
beaches and in England drive an
unlimited distance to get there you can
meet one person from another household
while you're out
but that's your lot so mum or dad but
not both together child minders are
encouraged to work again meanwhile
vulnerable children and those of key
workers are now being urged to attend
school although this is not legally
binding step two starts in June at the
earliest this may be when you can meet
people freely from other households but
the document has nothing concrete on
that yet the big aim of this period is
for all primary children to go back to
school at the end of June secondary
schools are out for the summer apart
from year 10 and year 12 peoples who
will get some face to face contact
non-essential shops can reopen from
early June if the infection is on the
wane provided they follow coronavirus
guidance your favorite sporting events
and concerts can also now take place
from June become watch them in person
that might be not that might not be
possible anytime this year
who needs atmosphere anyway it may be
less than two months away but July the
fourth is the earliest date that step
three could be implemented this is broad
brush and still feels like it needs a
lot of work by any measure that plans
for what are to be opening at this point
are ambitious hairdressers presumably
cloaked in protective gear pubs and
restaurants maybe
those with outside space cinemas with
seats left empty this is all
aspirational rather than a detailed plan
Boris Johnson made clear everything in
this blueprint depends on the infection
rate dropping further but reopening the
country also depends on getting the
detail and the politics right it could
also be scuppered by unions or employers
or even devolved governments rejecting
Whitehall's of advice the disease isn't
the only hurdle for the prime minister